this is the first time Jamel Jabara has
planted trees on this piece of land in
California his harvest of abogados
should make him a profit in two years
but while the climate is not a threat
the location is the land is an area see
a term describing more than half of the
occupied West Bank that falls under full
Israeli control here Palestinians need
Israeli approval to build or develop
their lands but all around them new
Israeli settlements are sprouting up
here it's a risk but if we keep being
scared then we won't do anything yes
Israelis have the stronger hand when it
comes to control but we shouldn't leave
our lands German received support from a
Palestinian government project to farm
the land the government says it will
disregard Israeli control over the area
but that might be easier said than done
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has promised many times to
apply Jewish sovereignty over there the
latest his pledge of annexing the Jordan
Valley if he wins the Palestinian
leadership says it's not just a threat
of course he's using this as a ploy to
pander to his extreme right-wing racist
at the base but at the same time he's
been implementing this on the ground
gradually below the radar in some cases
but now with Trump and this
administration and the u.s. there is no
need to fly below the radar he is now
completely and specifically carrying out
these steps and declaring them and
announcing them whether Netanyahu
remains in power or not observers say
political progress in the occupied
territory is unlikely Joseph II there is
a revolt in the terminology used in
Israel the discourse now is a political
settlement that C is keeping the Israeli
settlements and outpost as it is they
talk about the Jordan Valley as a place
they can give up there was never
consensus about these issues in the past
for many Palestinians it doesn't matter
who leads the government as Israel
shifts more to the right the Israeli
elections heavily influenced
Palestinians lives but they don't have a
say in them in DI brahim al Jazeera the
occupied West Bank